hallo und herzlich willkommen bei ZDF
heute live ich freue mich dass Ihr dabei
seid wir haben hier vorhin schon über
die Personalentscheidung gesprochen über
die das politische Berlin auch sonst
gerade alle in Deutschland sprechen
Boris Pistorius wird
Verteidigungsminister und damit der
Nachfolger von Christine Lambrecht ja
und Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat dazu
heute schon ein schriftliches Statement
abgegeben indem er Pistorius als
herausragenden Politiker bezeichnet hat
und jetzt warten eigentlich alle darauf
dass er sich gleich noch vor der Presse
äußern wird nämlich in Brandenburg an
der Havel da ist Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz gerade mit Außenministerin
Anna-Lena Werbung am Bundesamt für
auswärtige Angelegenheiten ihr seht hier
die Bilder wir warten alle schon ganz
gespannt dass er dort voll die Presse
trifft und da sind wir mit ZDF heute
live natürlich dabei und im Anschluss
wird auch Boris pistoleos ein Statement
geben und auch darüber wollen wir
sprechen gemeinsam mit Euch und mit
meiner Kolleginnen und ZDF Hauptstadt
und
CDU-Außenpolitiker Roderich Kiesewetter
wenn ihr Fragen an Diana die mir schon
zugeschaltet ist hallo
andiana oder an Roderich Kiesewetter
habt oder eure Meinung zum Thema teilen
wollt dann schickt uns gerne eure Fragen
eure Kommentare hier in den youtube-chat
oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de jetzt sage ich aber
noch mal hallo Diana schön dass du bei
uns bist
Diana was sind denn so bei dir in Berlin
die ersten Reaktionen aus dem
politischen Berlin auf diese
Personalentscheidung heute Vormittag ja
es scheint fast so als wenn sich schon
viele darauf gefreut hätten ihre
Kommentare abzulassen wir haben schon
einen ganzen bunten Strauß fangen wir
mal bei der Opposition an die CDU hat
sich darüber beschwert dass der Kanzler
wieder einmal sich nicht nach
Fachkompetenz gerichtet habe sondern
nach Loyalität und parteilogik das ist
die Kritik die von der CDU kommt die AFD
geht etwa in dieselbe Richtung aber auch
das Friendly Fire ist so friendly nicht
die verteidigungspolitische Vorsitzende
des Verteidigungsausschusses Frau Strack
Zimmermann von der FDP sagt sie begrüßt
dass einerseits andererseits hoffe sie
sehr dass Pistorius am Kabinettstisch
ganz ausschließlich die Interessen der
Soldaten und soldatenvertrete nur dann
werde er auch unterstützt werden von ihr
die Grünen haben sich geäußert da vor
allen Dingen Katharina dröge die
Vorsitzende die gesagt hat es sei grünes
Selbstverständnis und auch
selbstverständlich für die Grünen dass
die Hälfte der Plätze am Kabinettstisch
mit einer Frau besetzt sind also
ziemlich deutlicher Druck in die
Richtung die Parität wieder herzustellen
Herr Habeck der Wirtschaftsminister hat
sich geäußert er schätze Pistorius sehr
und habe ihn als verlässlich und
verbindlich erlebt
er ist der Ansicht dass der große
Nervenstärke habe dass natürlich ist
etwas was man momentan gut gebrauchen
kann und dann haben wir noch tatsächlich
eine Stimme die aus Niedersachsen
rüberkommt der Ministerpräsident weil
bisheriger Chef Pistorius Lob diesen
glaubt er über dein hervorragender
Verteidigungsminister werden und
streicht noch einmal hervor dass er in
militärkontakten durchaus Erfahrung habe
Niedersachsen sei ja ein sehr großer
Bundeswehrstandort und Pistorius habe
immer einen sehr guten Draht zum Militär
gehabt das deutet noch einmal darauf hin
dass die SPD versucht diese
militärpolitische Kompetenz die
Pistorius eigentlich fehlt ein bisschen
schön zu reden
ja das sind auf jeden Fall schon einige
Reaktionen aus allen politischen Lagern
die es so gibt noch mal Stichwort
Parität das hatte sich der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz ja damals ein bisschen auf
die Fahne geschrieben ich habe eben noch
mal geguckt er hat ein Versprechen
gegeben dass ein Kabinett von ihm auf
jeden Fall paritätisch besetzt sein wird
das ist jetzt nicht mehr der Fall wie
schätzt du das denn ein ist das die
nötige Konsequenz jetzt oder kann man
ihn dafür schon kritisieren ja das
Problem ist einfach Fachkräftemangel in
der Bundesregierung es gab einfach
niemanden der die ganzen Kriterien die
sich Scholz und viele andere gewünscht
haben auch erfüllt hätte es sollte
möglichst jemand sein mit
verteidigungspolitischer Expertise
jemand mit großer Führungserfahrung die
hat weil nicht Pistorius wenn auch nur
im auf Landesebene und es gab eben
niemanden der diese Kriterien auf sich
vereinigt hätte in den Augen von Scholz
und eine Frau ist und insofern hat er
jetzt beschlossen dass es wichtiger ist
das Verteidigungsministerium so zu
besetzen das ist ihm hoffentlich nicht
wieder Ärger macht das ist wohl die
Logik aus seiner Sicht aber der Druck
der Frauen und der Druck von den Grünen
wird natürlich anhalten zumindest es
wird sicherlich jetzt keinen großen
Aufstand geben dazu sind alle zu froh
dass ein Verteidigungsminister gefunden
ist aber bei der nächsten Besetzung muss
Holz aufpassen und sollte ihm noch eine
Frau von der Fahne gehen denn sie Feser
schickt sich an Kandidatin für den
Posten der
Ministerpräsidentin in Hessen zu werden
dann muss er für diesen Posten auf jeden
Fall wieder eine Frau finden und
möglichst für die nächste zu besetzende
Stelle ebenfalls eine
ja du sprichst ja dann schon das nächste
Ministerin Amt an was möglicherweise
irgendwie neu vergeben werden müsste ist
ganz interessant zu sehen wie solche
Versprechen oder solche Ansprüche ja
auch dann vielleicht manchmal der
Realpolitik weichen müssen wir warten
weiter ganz gespannt und sehen dass ich
da gerade noch nicht so viel tut
ich gucke hier einmal ob schon Stimmen
aus der Community rein
äh kommen hier fragt jemand auf Facebook
ist wenn oben Dahl inwiefern betrachtet
Olaf Scholz die Abberufung von Frau
Lambrecht als persönliche Fehler
Einschätzung also das klang jetzt in den
Statements die er bisher verlauten
lassen hat nicht so an oder Diana wie
schätzt du das ein
unterstützt und die Erklärung lautete ja
dahingehen dass die Medien daran schuld
sind dass sie zurückgetreten ist weil
man sich nicht auf ihre Arbeit
konzentriert habe sondern auf ihre
Personen man kann natürlich sagen die
Person hat so viel anders dazu gegeben
daran an ihr Kritik zu äußern dass das
auch kaum anders möglich war aber sie
hat sehr wenig Selbstkritik geäußert und
wenn wir von Scholz hören dass er ihre
Erklärungen dazu unterstützt dann muss
man sagen er geht da wahrscheinlich mit
in diesem Erklärungsansatz und versucht
das Ganze von sich möglichst
fernzuhalten er hat ja auch Frau
Lambrecht vor gar nicht allzu langer
Zeit noch als erstklassige Politikerin
Ministerin gepriesen so dass wenn er
heute Herrn pistorie ist als
herausragenden Politiker beschreibt das
auch nicht mehr ganz so ganz voll klingt
ja das stimmt das natürlich interessant
diese Beschreibung jetzt auch noch mal
in den Kontext der vorherigen
Beschreibung der Ministerin zu setzen
jetzt hat ja das hast du gerade gesagt
die CDU zum Beispiel kritisiert das in
den Augen der CDU nicht nach
Fachkompetenz besetzt wurde sondern auch
ein großer loyalitätsaspekt dabei war
ist das etwas was Olaf Scholz sehr
wichtig ist oder liegt es vielleicht
auch am Haus weil ja gerade die
Zusammenarbeit zwischen Kanzleramt und
Verteidigungsministerium in diesen
Zeiten ganz eng ist das ist sicherlich
beides der Fall also es ist ihm
sicherlich sehr wichtig er hat außerdem
darauf also er versucht jetzt jemanden
zu finden der tatsächlich
durchsetzungsstark ist und dieses
Verteidigungsministerium führt er musste
ja selber ziemlich viele Aufgaben in der
Verteidigungspolitik übernehmen musste
oder hat auf jeden Fall weil Frau
Lamprecht da einen Vakuum gelassen hat
und ihn auch ein bisschen hat
reinregieren lassen das ist bei
Pistorius nicht unbedingt zu erwarten
insofern braucht er dann natürlich
tatsächlich jemandem dem Erfolg vertraut
Pistorius ist seitdem er 16 ist
SPD-Mitglied man kann also sagen der ist
wirklich ein ein urgewächs in der SPD
und er hat sehr gute Verbindungen auch
in die Bundespolitik er hat selbst
versucht Parteivorsitzender zu werden er
hat sich wohl gerade bei
innenpolitischen Themen häufig in die
Bundespolitik eingemischt und hat er
gute Kontakte also er ist ein in Berlin
geschätzter Kollege bei der SPD und das
ist verscheut sicherlich sehr wichtig es
ist aber auch wichtig und auch das
betonte in seiner Pressemitteilung dass
er eben durchsetzungsstark und
meinungsstark ist und dass er ein großes
Herz hat das wird betont und das ist ein
etwas merkwürdige Bezeichnung in einer
Pressemitteilung des Bundeskanzlers aber
auch das deutet ein bisschen darauf hin
dass Scholz
betont was der Vorgängerin gefehlt hat
die war für ihr großes Herz nicht so
bekannt und die Hoffnung ist ein
bisschen dass historius jetzt die Truppe
leichter hinter sich zu bringen vermag
als das Frau Lambrecht hat
ja und wer dieser Mann mit dem
sagenumwobenen großen Herz ist was der
bisher gemacht hat und wofür steht das
gucken wir uns jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
an das haben nämlich Oliver dolker und
Fabian Köhler für uns zusammengefasst
als Innenminister in Niedersachsen hat
er sich einen Namen gemacht der Termin
gestern wohl einer seiner letzten in
dieser Funktion ob Boris Pistorius da
schon wusste dass er
Verteidigungsminister wird der
62-Jährige Jurist ist Durchsetzung stark
bezieht deutliche Positionen seit 1976
dabei 16 Jahre alt ist der SPD-Mitglied
der Sicherheitsexperte gilt in seiner
Partei als konservativ seine direkte Art
wird geschätzt Abitur kaufmännische
Lehre danach wer Dienst und ein Studium
der Rechtswissenschaften historius hat
zwei Töchter ist verwitwettet 2006 wird
der Oberbürgermeister in Osnabrück
seiner Geburtstag statt danach holt ihn
Niedersachsens Ministerpräsident Stefan
weil in seinem Kabinett zehn Jahre macht
er dort pannenfrei seinen Job
Pistorius werden schon seit längerem
bundespolitische Ambitionen nachgesagt
2019 bewirbt er sich als Doppelspitze um
den SPD-Vorsitz scheitert aber jetzt
Verteidigungsminister in schwierigen
Zeiten übernimmt er den Posten der auch
schnell zum Schleudersitz werden kann
pur schleudersitzer stellt gerade jemand
aus der Community die Frage nämlich
Niklas auf YouTube
ist heidigungsministers nicht
zwangsleute zwangsläufig zum Scheitern
verurteilt Diana wie würdest du denn
dieses Amtes Verteidigungsminister
vielleicht verglichen mit anderen
Minister
Ämtern so einschätzen was brauchst da
was sind die Schwierigkeiten also es ist
auf jeden Fall ein ein gefährlicher Job
wenn man noch Karriere machen will dass
das muss man glaube ich so sagen es gab
ja auch verschiedene
Verteidigungsminister die danach in der
Versenkung verschwunden sind die letzte
war Frau kam Karrenbauer auch vor
Lambrecht würde ich jetzt nicht ähm eine
glänzende Zukunft in der Bundespolitik
Vorhersagen wollen Ursula von der Leyen
ist natürlich eine Ausnahme die hat es
wenn auch auf anderen Parkett dann nach
ganz oben geschafft und an Herrn
schaping in der Badewanne erinnern wir
uns oder für mehr im Planspiel erinnern
wir uns auch alle noch gerne es ist
natürlich ein sehr ernstes Ministerium
und man muss es auch sehr ernst nehmen
insofern ist glaube ich die Tatsache
dass Pistorius eben seine Ämter bisher
pannenfrei erledigt hat ein Versprechen
dass Scholz gerne in die Zukunft sehen
möchte
es ist außerdem so dass es ein sehr
Personal starkes Ministerium ist ist es
ein sehr großes Ministerium und man muss
eben nicht nur die Leute im Ministerium
hinter sich bringen sondern auch die
Soldaten und Soldaten das ist also sehr
viel Führung gefragt sehr viel
zwischenmenschlicher Kontakt und
Überzeugungskraft um dieses Amt zu
führen und insofern ist es vielleicht
ganz gut dass Pistorius schon 62 ist und
wahrscheinlich keine großartige Karriere
mehr sonst anstrebt und seine Kraft und
seine Konzentration jetzt voll auf das
Verteidigungsministerium richten kann
das ist auf jeden Fall ein interessanter
Punkt also das Verteidigungsministerium
vielleicht nicht als Karriere
Sprungbrett sondern wirklich als
allumfassende Aufgabe an der einige
schon gescheitert sind hier fragt noch
jemand aus der Community und zwar Niklas
Kreis Bräunig wie schnell kann man denn
nun mit Änderungen im BMVg rechnen also
wie einfach ist es überhaupt du hast es
gerade angesprochen in so einem großen
Haus mit so einer Personalstärke
wirklich Veränderung herbeizuführen ich
glaube das ist tatsächlich wahnsinnig
schwer und deswegen gibt ähm ist
natürlich auch tatsächlich immer mal
wieder stimmen die zu recht sagen die
Kritik an Christine Lambrecht war etwas
scharf dafür dass sie dieses riesige
Ministerium übernommen hat was ohne hin
wirklich problembehaftet ist und das
ganze in der Lage wo wir aus dem Frieden
in einer dem Krieg doch sehr viel nähere
Situation gekommen sind und die
Dringlichkeit der Aufgabe sehr viel
größer war man hat eben nicht nur auch
im mit dem Ministerium zu tun sondern
auch mit der Rüstungsindustrie es ist
alles nicht so einfach wie man sich das
gemeinhin vorstellt
Milliarden Euro jetzt zum Beispiel
auszugeben an Sondervermögen und in neue
Waffen und neue Munition zu investieren
das klingt leichter als gesagt das muss
erst bestellt und produziert werden und
getestet und was ich was alles also ich
glaube nicht dass da jetzt ruckartig
neue Veränderungen anstehen aber was
natürlich schnell zu verändern es ist
die Kommunikation und die war unter
Christine lambrecht
schlecht ich glaube so muss man es sagen
da erhofft sich Scholz mit Sicherheit
eine Verbesserung und das ist auch zum
Beispiel das was Frau stark Zimmermann
vom Verteidigungsausschuss noch mal
angemahnt hat dass sie auch wirklich
hofft dass jetzt da jemand hinkommt mit
einer besseren Kommunikationsleistung in
jede Richtung und das wird auch gefragt
sein in Bezug auf die internationalen
Partner der Bundesrepublik am Freitag
findet ein Treffen der Ukraine
Kontaktgruppe in Rammstein statt auf
Einladung der USA und da geht es unter
den Bündnispartnern darum wie es jetzt
weitergehen soll mit der Hilfe für die
Ukraine und da muss Pistorius eben schon
positionieren für Deutschland und da ist
natürlich gefragt was Deutschland dazu
sagt nachdem Scholz sehr vollmundig die
Zeiten wenn der angekündigt hat und sie
bisher auf sich warten lässt
ja du sagst es gerade schon vielleicht
noch die anschließende Frage des Users
wie lange muss kann dafür Pistorius sich
dann einarbeiten so wie das bei dir
gerade angeklungen ist da sind ja schon
wichtige Termine diese Woche ne also da
könnte man ausgehen von vielleicht zwei
drei Tagen ja genau zwei drei Tage um
Verteidigungsminister zu werden das ist
tatsächlich ziemlich hart wiederum Frau
Streik zu Mama hat gesagt er habe keine
Schonfrist so muss man das wohl sagen
Freitag ist dieses Treffen und da muss
er in irgendeiner Form in Erscheinung
treten es wird wohl jeder Verständnis
haben dass er sich da nicht bis ins
letzte Detail auskennt aber der hat viel
zu tun
der hat viel zu tun und ich denke ich
spreche für uns beide wenn wir sagen wir
bleiben da dran danke Diana dass du bei
uns warst und unsere Fragen beantwortet
hast gerne
ja und so lange Olaf Scholz noch nicht
vor der Pressewand steht und wir uns
anhören können was er zu dieser
Personalentscheidung sagt so lange
schalte ich noch mal rüber zum oberste
Reserve und CDU Außenpolitiker rodrig
Kiesewetter mit dem ich auch über diese
wichtige Personalentscheidung sprechen
möchte hallo
Frau Reichelt ich grüße Sie Herr
giesewetter für viele war ja diese
Entscheidung heute morgen eine kleine
Überraschung wie überrascht waren sie
ja das war schon eine Überraschung aber
es war klar dass es keinen geeigneten
fdp-verteidigungspolitiker oder
verteidigungspoliterin gibt denn Frau
Högel hat das Parlament verlassen aber
auch Fritz Felgentreu ist von sich
ausgegangen weil die SPD das 2% Ziel
verweigert hat und bewaffnete Drohnen
also insofern war die personalde dünn
aber so überraschend so clever ist die
Entscheidung auch dessen politischer
Vollprofi ich kenne ihn noch als ich
Präsident ist was er wissen verwandtes
war was Veranstaltungen in Niedersachsen
wer hat das Herz auf dem rechten Fleck
er muss jetzt beweisen dass er in der
Lage ist international zu können
Deutschland hat den Anspruch wichtige
Führungsmacht in Europa zu sein in dem
Sinne bisher nicht gerecht geworden und
er muss die zeitenwände umsetzen Frau
Zimmermann sagte eben zu Recht da ist
noch nichts in der Bundeswehr angekommen
sind bisher viele Lippen Bekenntnisse
aber ich glaube das Pistorius jemand ist
der den Ernst der Lage begreift und ich
war ja aktive Offizier und kein
Reservist die Bundeswehr braucht
braucht eine Führung die ein Herz für
die Soldatinnen und Soldaten hat und das
ist endlich mal besser wird in den
Streitkräften und da hat historius
nichts zu verlieren nur zu gewinnen
aus der CDU kam ja heute morgen auch so
ein bisschen die Kritik die SPD oder
Olaf Scholz hätte jetzt mal wieder nicht
nach Kompetenz besetzt sondern vor allem
auch nach Loyalität ihm gegenüber jetzt
hat ja aber pistorisch das haben wir
gerade in dem Stück gesehen ja auch
eindeutig sicher als Erfahrung wie
schätzen Sie das denn ein
ja ich habe sie eben selbst gesagt ich
kenne ihn und weiß auch um seine
Kompetenz wir als Opposition sind
natürlich auch sehr gespannt wie er sich
entwickelt er hat nur diese eine Chance
und er muss sich bereits am Freitag
berühren denn es erwarten die
mittelosteuropäischen Länder ist
erwarten die skandinavischen die
baltischen Länder dass wir eine ganz
wichtige Entscheidung treffen nämlich
dass Deutschland erstens den Export von
Leopard zwei Panzern in die Ukraine frei
gibt und zweitens selber welche liefert
die Ausbildung beginnt mit der Industrie
die Ertüchtigung beginnt und es kommt
ganz einfach drauf an dass dieser
Minister jetzt nicht verlängerte Arm ist
Kanzleramt ist sondern die Zeiten Wände
selbst gestaltet und vor allen Dingen
auch nicht diese Verhinderungsgründe
fortsetzt die wir oft gehört haben wo
ein Wille ist ist auch ein Weg die
Ukraine muss Segeln die ihnen befreit ja
muss seine eigenen von Russland
besetzten Gebiete befreien und sie
verteidigt unsere Freiheit weil Russland
angekündigt hat nach der Ukraine und das
Baltikum anzugreifen also ich glaube die
ist jemand der auch mit dem ich sehr als
der Innenminister war sehr gut
zusammengearbeitet hat und begreift das
ist ein Krieg auch gegen uns ist von
Russland und deshalb ist ihm der Ernst
der Lage gewiss bewusst aber eine andere
zweite Chance hat er nicht
ja und dazu passt auch gerade eine Frage
aus der Community die quasi live hier
reinfliegt nämlich fragt Karl der Große
auf Youtube denken sie denn dass ich
jetzt an der Ukraine Unterstützung etwas
ändern wird mit dieser neuen Besetzung
also wenn Karl der Große sich hier
meldet ganz wichtig ist dass Sie Lenski
den Karlspreis bekommt dieses Jahr im
Mai und zu zeigen dass Europa hinter ihm
steht und zweitens es muss sich etwas
ändern denn wenn die Ukraine zerfällt
werden Millionen von Menschen aus der
Ukraine zu uns kommen das halten unsere
Zivilgesellschaft nicht aus und zweitens
ist das für Russland dann Einladung
weiter zu machen wie angekündigt gegen
Moldau und das Baltikum vorzugehen dann
haben wir einen jahrelang
abnutzungskrieg und es kommt jetzt
darauf an alles zu tun dass die Ukraine
in diesem Jahr ein eine
Verhandlungsposition kommt und ihre
Gebiete zurück gewinnt die Russland seit
Januar letzten Jahres besetzt hat was
mir mit den Gebieten machen die seit
2014 besetzt sind muss politisch
ausgehandelt werden aber deutschland
droht ein gravierender
Reputationsverlust der Bundeskanzler hat
immer Führung angemahnt aber sie nicht
gebracht im europäischen Kontext macron
hat den übertrumpft beiden hat ihn ein
bisschen unter die Fittiche genommen und
jetzt ist die Aufgabe des
Verteidigungsministers das Kanzleramt zu
entlasten wir haben andere Aufgaben und
das Verteidigungsministerium und die
180.000 Soldaten und 60.000
Zivilbeschäftigten auch zu führen eine
Perspektive zu geben die zeitenwände
umzusetzen und vor allen Dingen deutlich
zu machen dass 100 Milliarden für die
Bundeswehr nicht ausreichend sondern
deutlich mehr benötigt werden damit wir
wieder ein glaubwürdiger und
verlässlicher Partner werden
ja das hatte Kanzler Scholz ja damals
bei seiner Zeitenwende Ankündigung auch
mit angekündigt eben als Deutschland
eine führende Rolle in der
bündnisverteidigung einzunehmen wir
haben hier noch eine sage ich mal
administrative Frage die viele Menschen
in unserer Community in den letzten
Tagen immer wieder bewegt hat und zwar
ist das einmal auf Youtube Prince of
Tales mit einem Statement er sagt ich
denke auf diesen Posten gehört jemand
von der Bundeswehr und dann fragt Timo
Hundertmark passend dazu wo ist denn die
militärische Erfahrung von Herr
historius wer Dienst ist da doch etwas
wenig denn dann könnt ihr auch ich bald
Minister werden was sagen sie denn dazu
braucht es eigentlich jemand mit mehr
militärischer Erfahrung auf seinem
Ministerposten oder ist das zweitrangig
ein umgekehrt das ist viel wichtiger
dass die deutsche Generalität die
Spitzen und Offiziere mutiger werden und
viel besser die politische Leitung des
Hauses beraten sie sind viel zu
zurückhaltend und haben vieles laufen
lassen die Generalität muss
ungefilterten militärischen Ratschlag
geben das ist in den letzten Jahren
schließlich vernachlässigt worden und
muss die politische Leitung des Hauses
muss ein Herz und ein Ohr für die lange
bis Militärs haben wir brauchen eine
strategische Kultur wir müssen
anerkennen dass die Grammatik des
Krieges inzwischen ich sag mal die
Rechtschreibung in Europa bestimmt und
deshalb müssen wir ganz arg aufpassen
dass wir jetzt nicht zu einer
Militarisierung führen sondern das
Militär aufwerten aber Politiker und
Politikerinnen auswählen die ein
Verständnis für militärische
Zusammenhänge haben die strategisch
denken die geopolitische Erfahrungen
haben und nicht einfach daher schwätzen
und das hatten wir leider immer wieder
mal in der Vergangenheit und Herr Struck
hätte mir sehr sind und sicherlich in
Weste Erinnerung aber als Frau von der
Leyen und Frau kramp-bauer die
Trendwenden umsetzen wollten hat der
Vizekanzler Scholz ein Veto eingelegt
und das 2 % viel verhindert also
insofern ist die Zeitenwende zumindest
mental in der SPD angekommen es die FDP
und die Grünen sind viel weiter als die
SPD in der Koalition und deswegen hoffe
ich dass auch von FDP und Grünen
notwendigen Impulse ausgehen dass
Deutschland außen und
sicherheitspolitisch wieder ein
verlässlicher Partner ist der auch mal
vorangeht der europäische koordiniert
der Vorstellungen von der Zukunft
Europas entwickelt und auch klar macht
dass die Ukraine in die Europäische
Union und mittelfristig auch in die NATO
gehören wir müssen uns
sicherheitspolitisch besser aufstellen
und dazu bedarf es Politiker die
sicherheitspolitisch denken können und
einer Generalität die klug ist und berät
und nicht einfach wartet und und
schweigt und und Minister in Desaster
laufen lässt
und ich sehe gerade dass in diesem
Moment Scholz vor die Presse Tritten da
haben wir jetzt direkt mal rein
ich freue mich für großes Interesse für
diese Behörde das Auswärtigen Amtes das
Bundesamt für auswärtige Angelegenheiten
dass schon heute aber auch in der
Zukunft eine ganz ganz große Rolle
spielen wird für die Zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres Landes wir wissen dass wir hoch
attraktiv sind dass viele mal Urlaub
machen wollen in Deutschland das ganz
viele auch das Bedürfnis haben hier zu
studieren zu arbeiten die Zukunft für
sich selber zu gewinnen und für uns geht
es ja auch darum wir wissen dass wir
unsere Zukunft die Leistungsfähigkeit
unserer Volkswirtschaft die
Leistungsfähigkeit auch unsere sozialen
Sicherungssysteme nur gewährleisten
können wenn wir über genügend Fachkräfte
verfügen aus der Europäischen Union ist
das nicht so schwierig denn da gibt es
Freizügigkeit im Hinblick auf die übrige
Welt ist das eine größere
Herausforderung und das muss ja alles
geordnet nach Regeln vor sich gehen ist
darf da nichts schief gehen wenn das
passiert und darum ist es wichtig dass
wir eine hochleistungsfähige be
die Entscheidung des Auswärtigen Amtes
hier eine Behörde in Brandenburg zu
etablieren ist richtig sie ist
zukunftsweisen sie ist die Grundlage
dafür dass wir das schaffen auch
übrigens im Zusammenhang mit all den
notwendigen digitalisierungsprozessen
und da geht es ja nicht nur darum heute
vorhandene Verfahren die auf dem Papier
da sind irgendwie zu digitalisieren
sondern wir müssen in der
Digitalisierung auch unglaubliche
Effizienz Gewinne möglich machen damit
die Arbeit einfacher wird und sich auf
das Wesentliche konzentrieren kann
grundlage dafür sind natürlich auch ganz
viele tolle Frauen und Männer die hier
arbeiten die hier an diesem Standort oft
auch wohnen und die hier etwas aufbauen
das für die Zukunft Deutschlands wichtig
ist und darüber freue ich mich und ich
bin sehr dankbar dafür dass das der Fall
ist für mich war das und auch für die
Außenministerin ein ganz erfreulicher
Besuch und wir glauben darauf können wir
aufbauen für eine der ganz großen
Herausforderungen Aufgaben
der die sich unserem Land stellen
eine weitere Bemerkung würde ich gerne
noch machen ich habe Boris Pistorius
gebeten
Bundesminister der Verteidigung zu
werden er ist nicht nur ein Freund und
ein guter Politiker sondern auch jemand
der über sehr sehr viele Erfahrungen in
der Sicherheitspolitik verfügt der sehr
offen und eng auch in seiner bisherigen
Funktion mit der Bundeswehr
zusammengearbeitet hat und der auch die
Kraft und Ruhe besitzt die man für eine
so große Aufgabe angesichts der jetzigen
Zeitenwende braucht ich bin mir
überzeugt dass das jemand ist der mit
der Truppe kann und denen die Soldaten
und Soldaten sehr mögen werden und ich
bin sehr dankbar dass er ja gesagt hat
und wir freuen uns auf die gute
Zusammenarbeit mit dem Ministeriums
ich will nicht versorgen mich auch noch
mal bei der Bundesministerin der
Verteidigung zu bedanken für Ihre Arbeit
die sie geleistet hat und noch mal klar
sagen großer Respekt für die
Entscheidung die sie gestern getroffen
hat schönen Dank
genau hier haben wir jetzt Scholz gehört
zum einen am Anfang zur Behörde wegen
der wir aber natürlich nicht live sind
er hat Pistorius angekündigt er hat ihn
als Freund als guten Politiker
bezeichnet und noch mal die enge oder
die große Erfahrung im Bereich
Sicherheitspolitik ähm herausgestellt
und darüber sprechen wir jetzt noch mal
mit Diana Zimmermann die mir hier wieder
zugeschaltet ist hallo Diana hallo Diana
was ist dein erster Eindruck von diesem
kurzen und knappen statement
ja erstmal humorig er bedankt sich für
das große Interesse für
diesen Standort des Auswärtigen Amtes in
Brandenburg an der Havel dass er den
eröffnet hat und natürlich weiß er dass
das große Interesse seiner Bemerkung zu
Boris Pistorius Guide und auf den kann
man dann tatsächlich auch zu sprechen
und interessant ist dass er zuerst sagt
es ist ein guter Freund das bestätigt
ein bisschen die Stimmen die sagen es
geht ihm sehr stark um Loyalität dann
ging es darum was für ein guter
Politiker ist wie viel Erfahrung er in
sicherheitsdingen hat dass ist wieder
eine leicht geschönte Art und Weise
darüber zu sprechen dass er eigentlich
Innenpolitiker ist aber eben jetzt eine
einen zarten Touch von strategischer
Erfahrung angehaftet bekommt wenn es um
militärische Dinge geht und dann hat er
gesagt er glaube er werde einen guten
Draht zur Truppe bekommen das ist
natürlich ganz wesentlich er glaubt
einfach dass Pistorius von seiner
Persönlichkeit her jemand ist der mit
den Soldaten und Soldaten gut können
wird und das war sicherlich eines der
entscheidenden Kriterien für Scholz ihn
auch zu wählen
ja was ich auch noch mal interessant
fand dass er zum Schluss ja Christine
Lambrecht noch mal gedankt hat ihr
großen Respekt gezahlt hat Diana wie
schätzt du das ein geht man da im
schlechten auseinander oder sieht das
wirklich wie nach vorne nach einer
friedlichen Einigung nach einem
friedlichen auseinanderscheiden aus
[Musik]
also ich fand das ist auch eher
freundschaftlich klang es klang ein
bisschen so nach dem Motto wie in der
Regierung sind alle gute Freunde
miteinander und es sorgt natürlich auch
dafür dass Kritik an Frau Lambrecht
nicht zu laut wird wenn er sich noch
einmal deutlich hinter sie stellt dann
schützt er sich auch selbst dann
schließlich hat er sie ernannt und hat
in letzter Zeit auch noch mal von ihr
als erstklassiger Politikerin gesprochen
wenn er jetzt da öffentlich im unguten
mit ihr auseinander gehen würde dann
wäre das ein Eingeständnis seine eigenen
Fehleinschätzung und für die ist der
nicht bekannt
ja und wir warten übrigens auch noch
darauf dass Berufs Pistorius sich äußert
das war angekündigt wir gucken aber mal
wann wir da Bilder bekommen ich gucke
noch mal was die Community so sagt
hier gibt's so ein bisschen
pessimistische Stimmung das können wir
ja schon vom Polen da sagt zum Beispiel
Julia Kaiser die Bundeswehr wurde jetzt
seit Jahrzehnten vernachlässigt nach
vernachlässigt so etwas kann man denke
ich nicht innerhalb einer
Legislaturperiode erledigen das spielt
ja so ein bisschen darauf an was du auch
gesagt hast das ist vielleicht nicht der
posten wenn man jetzt noch ganz groß
Karriere danach machen möchte sondern es
ist wirklich eine schwere Aufgabe
und ich guck mal ob wir schon Bilder
kriegen dann aber wir kriegen noch keine
Bilder
Diana was sagst du denn dazu dass
Roderich Kiesewetter jetzt ja gerade
auch noch mal gesagt hat dass er
eigentlich hohe Hoffnungen setzt ist
dann sind dann die Meinungen in der
Union gehen die dann auch auseinander ja
das ist sehr interessant diese Wetter
ist ein ausgesprochener
verteidigungspolitischer Experte und er
hat ja gesagt er kennt Pistorius selbst
insofern hat das durchaus Gewicht wenn
er so spricht natürlich ist aber die
Opposition Darm Opposition zu machen und
der Punkt den ähm Herr Wade Pool heute
auch im Mittagsmagazin gemacht hat bei
uns ist ja der dass eben Pistorius kein
ausgewiesener verteidigungsexperte ist
und der kommt man auch nicht drumherum
da kommt man auch nicht drumherum als
Kanzler Scholz indem man sagt der habe
irgendwie einen guten Draht zum Militär
gehabt als er in Niedersachsen
Innenminister war weil Niedersachsen
eben auch ein großer Bundeswehr
Stützpunkt ist das sind natürlich
wirklich nur versuche zu Momente dass er
kein Verteidigungspolitiker ist
allerdings
der Herr Kiesewetter traut ihm das zu
und Scholz traut ihm das offensichtlich
auch zu dass er sich eben schnell
einarbeiten kann und dass er vom Typ her
und von der Erfahrung her der richtige
Mann ist um dieses sehr große und sehr
komplizierte Ministerium zu leiten
ja wir bleiben auf jeden Fall dran ich
habe gerade gehört dass
Pistorius quasi zeitgleich mit dem
Kanzler gesprochen hat da werden wir
später noch mal reingucken jetzt bedanke
ich mich aber erstmal bei dir Diana
vielen Dank dass du bei uns warst und
ich schalte noch mal rüber zu Roderich
Kiesewetter CDU Außenpolitiker
Herr Kiesewetter da sind wir wieder was
sagen sie denn zu diesem kurzen
pointierten Statement von Olaf Scholz
ja Olaf Scholz muss ich schon auch
fragen wie er seine Selbstkritik
empfindet aber auf die lange Sicht er
hat jetzt bereits den zweiten Minister
bzw zweite Ministerin verloren nach Frau
Spiegel jetzt Frau Lambrecht also zwei
Ministerin die nicht mal innerhalb eines
Jahres das Amt verlassen mussten also er
kann sich nicht weitere Schwächen
leisten zu mal das alles innerhalb der
SPD ist das erinnert mich ein bisschen
arg an 1998 als Lafontaine und der
Kanzleramtsminister Hombach damals auch
sehr rasch das verlassen haben aber im
Grunde genommen sollten wir nach vorne
blicken und auch als Oppositionen sind
wir natürlich da konstruktive andere
Vorschläge zu machen und uns liegt eben
die internationale Vernetzung
Deutschlands am Herzen und hier hat
Scholz bisher das Kanzleramt übersteuert
bzw Frau Lambrecht hatte nicht das
Gefühl vermittelt dass sie sich stark um
unsere Nachbarn kümmert weder um
Frankreich noch um Polen noch um die USA
sie ist auch eine der Minister
Verteidigungsministerin der
Vergangenheit die am wenigsten
Dienstreisen durchgeführt hat zu dem
Partnern und hier ist viel nachzuholen
und ich hoffe das Pistorius ich weiß
nicht wie er Englisch spricht wie sein
Englisch ist verhandlungssicher ob er
sehr rasch den die internationalen
Kontakte aufgreifen das ist die große
Chance jetzt am Freitag bereits im
ramsteinformat mit den ganzen
Unterstützung starten und am Sonntag mit
Frankreich wo ist das
deutsch-französische Regierungstreffen
gibt also das sind ja wir haben in
diesem Jahr 60 Jahre das sind ja ganz
entscheidende Punkte und da wird es ihm
schon etwas leicht gemacht aber hier
innere auch daran dass die SPD die
Transatlantiker in der Partei verdrängt
hat Eva Hügel ist jetzt werbeauftragte
Fritz felgentreuung unterrichtet jeder
Latein und Altgriechisch an seinem
Gymnasium und hat letztes in der letzten
Periode die Fraktion verlassen die SPD
muss angesichts dieser Krisen schon auf
sich auf die transatlantischen Wurzeln
besinnen und auf die Transfer dran für
Orientierung eines Helmut Schmidt und
damals hatten wir über 3% vom
Bruttoinlandsprodukt für Verteidigung
also hier ist erheblicher Nachholbedarf
und deshalb kommt auch darauf an dass
Pistorius trotz aller Loyalität
Eigenständigkeit entwickelt und sich
eben nicht zu verlängerten Amt des
Kanzleramts macht und wir müssen auch in
der Rüstungsindustrie daran denken dass
so etwas wie soll ich sagen eine
Umorientierung ist früher nannte man das
Kriegswirtschaft das also bestimmte
Verfahren beschleunigt werden das
Munition für die Bundeswehr hergestellt
wird aber auch für die Ukraine das
Ersatzteile beschafft werden das einfach
deutlich gemacht wird wir haben eine
Interesse an einer gut voll
ausgestatteten Bundeswehr der sonst ist
die Zeit meine tatsächlich es kann ja
vorhin andere Frau Zimmermann einen
Lippen Bekenntnis und das können wir uns
schlichtweg nicht leisten
ja sie haben gerade angesprochen das
Verhältnis zwischen Pistorius und Scholz
was sie sich wünschen wir haben ja auch
eine Stimme aus der Community dazu und
zwar schreibt auf Youtube der User senex
ich kann nur hoffen dass Herr Pistorius
Herrn Scholz auch mal wieder Worte gibt
und nicht immer diese zögerliche Schiene
mitträgt sonst wird es nicht vorangehen
ist das genau diese zögerliche Schiene
von der sie auch Sprachen dass sie im
Prinzip Lambrecht und Scholz quasi zu
sehr zusammen gesehen haben klassische
Satz der das beschreibt ist Russland
darf nicht gewinnen und die Ukraine darf
nicht verlieren ja was denn also in
jedem Fall muss die Ukraine wie macron
ist seit einer Woche sagt die Ukraine
muss siegen und das definieren wir dass
die Ukraine zumindest die Grenzen vom
Januar letzten Jahres wieder herstellt
also die russischen Besatzer wieder
rausgehen dass die Kindes Entführungen
aufgeklärt werden angeblich 10.000
Kinder entführt worden dass die
Kriegsverbrechen aufbereitet werden und
hier muss glaube ich der neue
Verteidigungsminister Klartext sprechen
dann muss unsere Reserve völlig neu
organisiert werden wir müssen schauen
wie die Blaulicht das bringt als
Innenminister ja mit
Blaulichtorganisation Bundesamt für
bevölkerungs-reserve wir müssen jetzt
auch unsere militärische Reserve
professionalisieren der
Reservistenverband muss ein zu einer Art
Körperschaft öffentliche rechts werden
mit einer viel stärkeren
aufgabenausstattung wir müssen auch
schauen wie wir das Thema
Freiwilligendienste ausweiten denn für
unsere Blaulichtorganisation und die
Bundeswehr sind gerade mal 100.000
Stellen vorgesehen aber im
Geburtsjahrgang hat 700.000 es gibt so
viele Baustellen die nötig sind auch die
Frage der Kriegsbilder was lernen denn
Russland und China aus dem Desaster auf
dem ukrainischen Boden also die müssen
wir unsere Streitkräfte dazu Zukunft
ausrichten die organisieren wir
europäische Sicherheit das neue Europa
nach dem Krieg wird osteuropäischer
tanzatlantischer verteidigungsbereiter
und digitaler sein ist Deutschland dort
Stolperstein oder sind wir Teil des
Ganzen also wir brauchen eine eine Art
strategische Kultur die die uns bewusst
macht auch der Bevölkerung erklärt wie
es weitergeht ein Gedanke noch der
Bundeskanzler hat 300 Milliarden Euro in
seiner comicsprache doppelbums in die
Hand genommen das ist richtig und die
Gesellschaft zusammenzuhalten aber er
erklärt nicht dass wir gerade mal ein
bisschen mehr als drei Milliarden Euro
also ein Prozent der Summe für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine aufwenden hier
kann er mehr auf die Bevölkerung
einwirken dass wir auch Bereiter werden
die Ukraine auch politisch stärker zu
unterstützen und dass sie die Stimmung
dreht das also Waffenlieferungen
weiterhin von einem Großteil der
Bevölkerung an die Ukraine zu unserer
eigenen Sicherheit befürwortet werden
ich halte das sehr wichtig um auch das
Vertrauen in Deutschland den Ruf
Deutschlands zu verbessern denn der hat
in den letzten zumindest im letzten Jahr
sehr gelitten
ja und wir gucken jetzt mal direkt in
die Bilder vom Statement von Pistorius
der hat nämlich zur gleichen Zeit wieder
Kanzler gesprochen und zwar an seiner
jetzt altenwerkstätte im Innenhof des
Innenministeriums Hannovers
vielen Dank dass Sie gekommen sind
vielen Dank für Ihr Interesse herzlich
willkommen
ein letztes Mal mutmaßlich hier in
niedersächsischen Innenministerium
ich habe sie hergebeten um mich
gewissermaßen zu verabschieden und ein
paar Worte zu verlieren über die neue
Aufgabe
der Bundeskanzler hat mich gefragt ob
ich das Amt des
Bundesverteidigungsministers in seinem
Kabinett übernehme das habe ich dem habe
ich sehr dankend und sehr gerne
zugestimmt das mache ich sehr gerne und
das ist mir eine wirklich
außerordentlich große Ehre dieses Amt zu
übernehmen ich
weiß um die Bedeutung der Aufgabe gerade
in diesen Zeiten und ich danke meiner
Vorgängerin wenn ich das schon so sagen
darf Christine Lamprecht für ihre Arbeit
in diesem besonders schwierigen
herausfordernden Zeiten sie hat die
Neuaufstellung unserer Bundeswehr in den
in der Zeitenwende begonnen
mein besonderer Dank gilt natürlich vor
allem den Bundeskanzler für das in mich
gesetzte Vertrauen
die Aufgaben die vor der Truppe liegen
sind gewaltig
ich werde deshalb meine Dienstgeschäfte
unmittelbar nach der Vereidigung am
Donnerstag aufnehmen und mich mit dem
Ministerium der Bundeswehr Führung und
natürlich auch den Parlamentarier und
den Parlamentariern austauschen
mir ist bei all dem und das hat meine
Arbeit hier auch im Innenministerium in
Niedersachsen stets geprägt wichtig der
enge und vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit
mit den Menschen die mir in diesem Amt
anvertraut sein werden mit den
Soldatinnen und mit den Soldaten die
Bundeswehr muss sich auf eine neue
Situation einstellen die mit dem
russischen Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine
entstanden ist mir ist wichtig die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten ganz eng in
diesem Prozess zu beteiligen und sie
mitzunehmen und die Truppe kann sich
darauf verlassen dass ich mich wann
immer es nötig ist vorgestellt werde ich
will die Bundeswehr stark machen für die
Zeit die vor uns liegt
vielen Dank
ja das sagt Herr Pistorius zu seiner
neuen Aufgabe Herr Kiesewetter was ist
ihre erste Reaktion auf dieses Statement
was ihre Einschätzung also er nimmt die
Aufgabe nicht nur an sondern er scheint
sie gern anzunehmen und dann nimmt sie
sehr ernst ihr müsst denke ich bewusst
was da auf ihm lastet er muss allerdings
auch begreifen dass die zeitenwände von
Frau Lambrecht nicht angepackt wurde und
dass die zeitenwände die die Trendwende
seit 2014 lief auch an den
haushaltsvorbehalten des damaligen
spd-finanzministers gescheitert ist wenn
er jetzt sagt wir müssen die Zeiten wenn
der anbringen und die Bundeswehr stark
machen kann ich ihm nur recht geben und
wenn er das auch mit Vernunft angeht und
das Parlament breit einbindet können wir
da auch Ansatzpunkte für eine
Unterstützung sehen mir ist wichtig dass
er die internationale Vernetzung der
Bundeswehr und vor allen Dingen die
internationale Rolle Deutschlands ernst
nimmt ernster ist der Kanzler tut mit
Blick auf die unterstützungserwartungen
und wenn das der Fall ist dann glaube
ich könnte das ein starker
Verteidigungsminister werden aber keine
Vorschusslorbeeren sondern wir wollen
ihn an seiner Arbeit messen und er
scheint es ja gleich ab Donnerstag zu
beginnen und das ist soll ich sagen ja
nichts anderes ist zu erwarten aber er
verbreitet den nötigen Ernst
ja Donnerstag ist Vereidigung am Freitag
ist dann das Treffen der Rammstein
Kontaktgruppe Herr Kiesewetter in ihren
Augen ganz kompakt Herr Pistorius hat
gerade davon gesprochen dass Frau
Lambrecht die Neuaufstellung der
Bundeswehr hinsichtlich der Zeitenwende
begonnen hat wie muss in ihren Augen
jetzt Herr Pistorius ganz konkret am
Freitag agieren was sind so die nächste
steps um diese neue Aufstellung
weiterzuführen
ja das muss ja selbst entscheiden und
wir sind ja keine Regierungsberater in
der Opposition aber es gibt drei
wesentliche Punkte erstens er muss die
Zeiten wenn du umsetzen und dabei wird
er sehr rasch feststellen dass die 100
Milliarden nicht ausreichen es ist ja
auch noch fast nichts in der Truppe
angekommen es sind gerade mal 11
Milliarden Euro für dieses und nächstes
Jahr für Ausgaben die Inflation greift
gravieren zu so dass die 100 Milliarden
inzwischen nur 83 Milliarden sind Leiste
muss deutlich machen wir brauchen bis
Ende des Jahrzehnts zusätzlich etwa 300
Milliarden Euro für die Bundeswehr
allein die Aufstockung der
Munitionsvorräte Bedarf 30 Milliarden
Euro das zweite ist und das ist in den
letzten Jahren auch zu unionszeiten
nicht angegangen worden das
Beschaffungswesen muss man Dennis wird
werden und ein gravierender Fehler der
2011 gemacht wurde Führung und
materialverantwortung gehören wieder
zusammen also die
teilkraftinfektoren also ein
generalmeister ja sehr bekannt ist muss
jeder verantwortlich werden für die
Einsatzbereitschaft des Materials das
kann man nicht outsourcen in
Anführungsstrichen an zivile Behörden
geben sondern die Truppe muss für ihr
Material verantwortlich sein und das
dritte ist die in der Truppe macht sich
eine Stimmung bereits so nach dem Motto
es ist egal wir uns führt es wird eh
nichts besser da braucht ein Herz für
die Stimmung der Soldaten und Soldaten
und das ist eben nicht das Ministerium
mit über oder knapp 4000 Angehörigen
sondern das sind 180.000 Soldaten und
Soldaten und 60.000 Zivilbeschäftigte
die muss er zeigen dass er ihr Inhaber
der befehls- und Kommando Gewalt ist
dass er ein Herz für sie hat gut mit der
werbeauftragten zusammenarbeiten dann
wird es etwas aber das sind die drei
wesentlichen Herausforderungen vor denen
dieser Minister steht
dass er die Soldaten und Soldaten auf
jeden Fall enger beteiligen will das hat
hat Pistorius ja gerade in seiner Rede
schon mal angedeutet Herr Kiesewetter
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns waren
danke für Ihre Einschätzung sehr gerne
alles Gute
genau wir haben jetzt die Worte gehört
von Scholz wir haben die Wörter gehört
von Pistorius ich gucke noch mal was ihr
so dazu sagt es gibt auf jeden Fall von
euch einige Kritik an der Kommunikation
von Scholz die ja doch recht locker
recht salopp war hier wird ähm z.B von
Wolfgang Schmidt auf Youtube gesagt
schön dass man den neuen
Verteidigungsminister im nachklappt er
beiläufig erwähnt kurzen Dank und das
war's da kann man mal sehen welchen
Stellenwert die Truppe bei unserem
Kanzler hat und auch Cover Syndicate auf
Youtube sagt ein verdienter general oder
Offizier wäre ein Highlight gewesen und
wäre ehrlich auch das Volk gestrahlt
jetzt bleibt wieder der Beigeschmack der
Fett an wird Wirtschaft aber nicht alle
sind so pessimistisch hier gibt's noch
einen abschließenden Kommentar der sagt
ich bin überzeugt dass das jemand ist
der mit der Truppe kann und den die
Soldaten und Soldaten mögen werden
ja wie Pistorius sich schlagen wird wie
es bei ihm weitergeht und was seine next
steps in diesem wichtigen Amt sind wir
bleiben da auf jeden Fall weiter für
euch dran danke dass ihr so fleißig mit
uns diskutiert habt und bis zum nächsten
Mal wenn ihr mögt
[Musik]